dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly July fair how cool
would it be to be able to place a
character representing us in a digital
film or a computer game of course it
would clearly be an extremely laborious
task to digitize the 3d geometry and the
albedo map of our face this albedo map
means a texture a colored pattern that
describes how our skin reflects and
absorbs light capturing such a
representation is clearly a very lengthy
and expensive process so get this
completely crazy idea this technique
creates this full digital representation
of any face from no more than one simple
photograph we can even get historical
figures in our digital universe all we
need is one photograph of them and now
feast your eyes on these incredible
results after taking the photograph this
technique creates two of these albedo
maps one is a complete low-frequency map
which records the entirety of the face
that only contains the rough details the
other albedo map contains finer details
but in return is incomplete do you
remember the texture synthesis methods
that we discussed earlier in the series
the input was a tiny Patras image with a
repetitive structure and after learning
the statistical properties of these
structures it was possible to continue
them indefinitely the key insight is
that we can also do something akin to
that here as well we take this
incomplete albedo map and try to
synthesize the missing details pretty
amazing idea indeed the authors of the
paper invoked a classical learning
algorithm a convolutional neural network
to accomplish that the deeper the neural
network we use the more high-frequency
details appear on the outputs or in
other words the crisper the image we get
in the paper you will find a detailed
description of the crowdsource user
study that was used to validate this
technique including the user interface
and the questions being asked there are
also some comparisons against patch
match one of the landmark techniques for
texture synthesis that we have also
talked about in an earlier episode it's
pretty amazing to see these two minute
papers knowledge-based grow and get more
and more intertwined I hope you're
enjoying the process as much as I do
also due to popular request the two
minute papers t-shirts are now available
this time we are using a different
service for printing these shirts please
give us some feedback on how you liked
it I've put my email address in the
video description if you attach a photo
of yourself wearing some cool two minute
papers merch will be even more delighted
just open two minute papers comm and
you'll immediately have access to it
this link will bring you to the service
that ships to the US the link for
shipping outside the US is available in
the video description thanks for
watching and for your generous support
now see you next time
[Music]